letzte woche war einiges los in meinem
leben und das möchte ich jetzt nicht nur
auf youtube bezogen mit der klub sache
und allgemein mich als öffentliche
person angehen sondern primär auf mein
privatleben bezogen also familie et
cetera außerdem noch nie wirklich eine
person die groß jetzt irgendwie private
informationen veröffentlicht hat also
über familie wohnungen auto einkommen
etc
aber ich glaube dass es in diesem fall
mir persönlich vielleicht auch irgendwie
helfen würde lieber sein ist kein beruf
wo ich irgendwie analysen schreibe oder
zahlen hinter dem computer wels oder
brötchen belege oder maschinen
zusammenbau oder keine ahnung war
sondern ich stehe in der öffentlichkeit
und dann ist es sehr schwer seinem beruf
nachzugehen wenn ein etwas emotional so
sehr zerfrisst dass man es nicht
überspielen kann ich habe dieses thema
allgemeinen letzten wochen nie wirklich
thematisiert auf meinem kanal und mehr
oder weniger von mir den öffentlichen
luca von youtube ferngehalten allerdings
glaube ich mittlerweile dass es
irgendwie vielleicht sinnvoll ist
darüber mit jemandem zu sprechen also
hier dieses video einfach zu machen aber
ich fange erst mal an zu erzählen
vor neun wochen ist mein opa gestorben
mütterlicherseits und das war schon was
wo man sich sage ich mal so ein bisschen
drauf vorbereitet hat weil er halt auch
viele krankheiten seit jahren hat
dennoch ist dann der moment wo man dann
wirklich den anruf bekommen von wegen
hey es ist jetzt passiert
das ist dennoch irgendwie so ein moment
vor einem jahr irgendwie gefühlt sondern
ein eiskaltes wasser ins gesicht
geschüttet wird für mich persönlich war
das der erste todesfall in
meiner familie von daher war es für mich
extrem komisch sage ich mal die ganze
familie sich beisammen finden zu sehen
und nicht irgendwie jetzt ostern oder
einen geburtstag zu feiern sondern halt
auf grund das ist halt ja kein schöner
anlass war die beisetzung fand dann
einige tage später statt und ich kann
mich noch genau daran erinnern alter als
meine oma da stand vor dem grab ihres
man kann das wirklich nicht in worte
fasst was man da für eine trauer aber
irgendwie auch wut falls was sinn ergibt
spürt irgendwie
besetzungen sind wir dann auf jeden fall
alle eine kirche noch mal gefahren zu
einem gottesdienst haben gebetet und als
dann die messe vorbei war sind wir noch
mal in kleinen kreis zum grab
hingefahren weil das grab ja dann fertig
hergerichtet war auf dem weg zum
friedhof hat mein vater dann allerdings
einen anruf bekommen dass man anderer
opa also der vater von meinem vater ins
krankenhaus gebracht wurde wir sind dann
folglich direkt nach der beerdigung
meines opas mütterlicherseits ins
krankenhaus gehetzt zu meinem opa
väterlicherseits daran lag und ich habe
ihn auch am nächsten tag dann noch mal
besucht mit juli bevor er nach köln
gefahren sind wie herr zu halten dazu
uns dass er eine lungenentzündung hat
aber er durchkommen würde und deswegen
liegt ja auch nicht allein auf einem
zimmer sondern mit zwei anderen leuten
auf einem dreibettzimmer und wir sind
dann auf jeden fall am abend nach köln
gefahren und am nächsten morgen hat mich
mein vater angerufen um 7 uhr oder so
dass auch ein anderer oper verstorben
ist
passierte übrigens auch kurze zeit
nachdem club skandal wenn man es so
nennen mag
und da haben ja auch schon danach die
ganzen medien und zeitungen und auch
große youtuber irgendwie in der luft
zerrissen förmlich ich war da schon
gefühlt emotional kurz vorm kollaps und
dann auch noch zwei tore in so kurzer
zeit das steckt man nicht einfach so
schnell wird mit meinen youtube videos
habe ich nach den beiden toten dann auf
jeden fall erstmal wieder normal weiter
gemacht weil ich erstens noch einige
vorproduziert hatte und zweitens es mich
auch wirklich abgelenkt hat einfach
sechs wochen nach den beiden
beerdigungen gab es dann noch mal so
einen sechs wochen seelenamt da trifft
man sich nochmals komplette familie und
geht zusammen die kirche und gedenkt
noch mal den toten und betet für sie
besucht noch mal dass graf xmpp und
danach ja mehr oder mehr also die
normalität wieder eingekehrt und jetzt
letztes wochenende also drei wochen
nachdem sechs wochen sind also neun
wochen nach den toten meiner beiden opas
bin ich mit meiner schwester und vier
freunden zum flughafen gefahren
es ist ein festival nähe von düsseldorf
und wir machen das halt einmal im jahr
das leben sommer zusammen festival
fahren mit kempen und so einfach feiern
wir waren dort auf jeden fall vom
letzten freitag bis zum montag jetzt vor
drei tagen und haben quasi gefeiert und
hatten einfach eine coole zeit und am
montagmorgen sind wir dann halt
aufgestanden haben geduscht und die
sachen gepackt und finden haben die
autos geholt und carola jule und sarah
haben bei dem gepäck an der straße
gewartet und ich bin noch mal zurück
gegangen aufs campinggelände und habe
noch einen tisch geholt den wir noch
mitnehmen wollten und dann hat mich mein
vater angerufen und ich bin halt als
handy gegangen und meinte hey was geht
wir packen gerade sachen zusammen
wollten jetzt gerade vom festival
losfahren kann ich später zurückrufen
dann hat er einfach gesagt und man ist
gestorben
also meine auch noch
wie bei meinem opa dass man sich
irgendwie schon darauf eingestellt hat
dass demnächst irgendwann den nächsten
monaten wochen oder tagen diese anrufe
kommen von wegen hey es ist jetzt vorbei
sondern es kam halt völlig aus dem
nichts doch mal war komplett gesund
hatte keine großen krankheiten nichts
wir haben alle mal gesagt die wir 250
jahre alt und ich habe mir selbst immer
so gesagt
wenigstens kriegt die noch mit so wie
meine kinder aufwachsen und sieht die
auf jeden fall habe ich dann halt
während des anrufs mit meinem vater war
ich quasi komplett versteinert mehr oder
weniger und hab halt dann hinten einer
straße gesehen so ja das sind gerade
meine freundin meine schwester und
carola die wissen alle drei noch nicht
was abgeht und das erste was sie dir
dann in den kopf schießt es erstmal wie
bringst du deiner kleinen schwester bei
dass gerade eure oma verstorbenes
nachdem vor einigen wochen schon beide
opas verstorben sind
danach das ist einfach nur keine ahnung
danach habe ich nur noch komplett trauer
gespürt wut ich habe mein handy durch
die gegend geworfen gegen zelt geheult
mit jule mit meiner schwester zusammen
wir waren ja immer noch auf dem
campinggelände und überall waren noch
andere youtuber es war ein satz wie ich
dafür habt ihr das waren ganz viele
youtuber alle bei dem festival und ein
paar waren noch da doch andere leute
also locker 20 30 leute saßen dann auch
ein bisschen an dem vorbei gelaufen und
ich hab dann halt nicht sagen können hey
ich bin gerade traurig weil das festival
vorbei ist
ich dachte nach dem fest
helfer alles mega cool war alles
megageil und in einer woche war ich mit
meiner kompletten familie den ort sehen
wir machen zusammen urlaub und lassen
jetzt die ganzen beschissenen erfahrung
hinter uns und dann wird man mit sondern
nachricht mit seinem anruf direkt wieder
in das loch zurückgezogen aus dem man
die letzte woche nach und nach heraus
geklettert ist als familie ist sich in
den letzten wochen auf jeden fall
verstanden habe ist die endgültigkeit
des todes so wie ich jetzt in meiner oma
fahre das dann nicht irgendwie da meine
ich fahre ich mal jetzt noch mal